[Music]
we all love a great Disney movie they
draw us in with fabulous stories full of
fun characters we've all wished we could
meet our favorites in person now you can
know exactly what they would look like
our last look-alike is too cute to miss
[Music]
if you're as obsessed with Disney as we
are smash that subscribe button don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up if you can't get enough Disney fun
now let's see the ten kids who look like
Disney characters in real life Mulan
who doesn't love Mulan she's tough brave
and unstoppable she honors her family
with her brave adventures and ends up
saving all of China she's kind of the
best obviously it's fun to imagine her
as a real person we love the animated
version but it's just not the same
there's a little girl in Japan who lets
us see what our beloved princess
may have looked like as a little girl
photographer Kawashima Kotori
couldn't help but be charmed by his
friends four-year-old daughter he
followed the little girl around the
globe from Japan to Paris on her
adorable adventures he assembles his
favorite shots into an award-winning
book called me reichan you can't deny
the resemblance this tiny little girl
has the same big bright eyes as mulan
those adorable brown eyes convey the
same curiosity intelligence and Wonder
as the warrior princess Mirai also makes
the same serious determined faces that
our expressive princess does they both
look serious enough to save their entire
country any kiddo that young with that
kind of gravity' is going places your
eyes joyful expressions capture the
energy of this spunky princess she's
just the cutest her little cheeks are so
rosy they look just like Milan's after
she had her makeup done for the
matchmaker Elsa and Anna frozen is one
of the best Disney Princess movies ever
the music is awesome the story is fun
and the characters are iconic Elsa and
Anna are a princess powerhouse they're
so popular that they've become their own
franchise we'd all love to see the
princesses in real life and it just so
happens we can a Florida teen was out
with her family when she saw a cardboard
cutout of Elsa
they couldn't help but notice a serious
resemblance her family asked her to pose
for a picture so they could show
everyone the adorable coincidence
at first the girl wasn't quite on board
she didn't feel put together and didn't
watch her photo taken but she eventually
gave in the best part her name is Eva
Nana talked about fate
18 year old on a faith Carlson is a dead
ringer for the ice queen her big blue
eyes are an unmistakable match she has
the same regal cheekbones to she's fair
just like Elsa and has the same icy
blonde hair honest spends her free time
dressing up as Elsa to visit schools and
children's hospitals her appearances are
free she does it just to see the kids
smile how sweet is that her sister Lexi
gets in on the fun too she dresses up as
Anna to accompany her on her visits
yellow and snow Aereo The Little Mermaid
is a Disney classic the film was
credited with beginning the Disney
Renaissance which reinvigorated the
company that makes Ariel a pretty
important princess she changed the
direction of the whole Disney Empire her
fiery red hair is iconic she has a
signature style that we all know and
love cosplayer Ashley may you be wolf
loves Ariel more than anyone she
dedicates a ton of time and skill to
make sure she looks exactly like the
mermaid princess her red hair is a
perfect match it's long full and so
bright she has Ariel's perfect
cheekbones - Ashley has Japanese
heritage she may use contacts to make
her eyes the perfect shade of blue to
match the princess she appears to be
bilingual as many of her Instagram posts
are in both English and Japanese
she's even smart and curious like Ariel
that's not the only trait she has in
common with the mermaid either ashley is
an avid collector - instead of
collecting human artifacts
Ashley collects all things little
mermaid she's just as big a fan as we
are her Instagram is full of pictures of
her awesome collection she has
everything from mermaid socks to
flounder purses her fandom is just too
cute linguini ratatouille is just one of
those movies you can't get enough of the
story is all about linguini a cook who
struggles under his demanding chef and
an adorable rat named Remy who dreams of
being a five-star chef the pair
inseparable and is a huge success this
movie is perfect for anyone who loves
good food and cute friendships well he
may not be best friends with a rat
this guy looks exactly like linguini his
name is Joshua carpenter Jones the best
part of this story might be what Joshua
does for a living
he's a kitchen porter that means he
spends every day in a kitchen doing all
the things linguini does every day he
even goes to work dressed as the
character Joshua is 19 and live in the
United Kingdom he says people constantly
tell him he looks like that guy from
that movie it might get annoying to
constantly be told you look like someone
else
Joshua seems to have a pretty good
attitude about it we just wish he had a
little fuzzy friend to ride around under
his hat rustle up is one of the most
beloved movies out there it's so moving
and emotional if you ask anyone about
the film they'll probably tell you how
it made them feel everyone loves the
adorable story of grumpy old man Carl
and his unlikely adventures we get to
see almost Paul of Carl's life in the
first 30 minutes of the film he meets
his childhood best friend marries her
buys a home and grows old you might
think that Carl's adventures might be
finished but the greatest time of his
life was about to begin
Carl hatches the plot to save his home
from demolition by floating it away he
uses an incredible amount of balloons to
lift his home into the sky after he's
already in flight he realizes his
neighbor Russell has come along for the
ride
Russell is a total cutie pie he's super
upbeat and really positive he's pretty
much the opposite of Carl this little
kiddo looks so much like the character
that the Internet is eating him up this
cosplay is one of the best we've ever
seen every detail is perfect and the
costume is perfect right down to the
merit badges
Russell is such a brave and upbeat
friend he's an awesome character to
emulate please
no Merida
we love brave it's one of the most
interesting princess movies ever written
Merida is super unique unlike most
Disney movies there isn't a love story
almost every other princess movie ends
with a big wedding if there isn't a
royal wedding there's at least a love
interest Merida is totally different
she's not interested in love she even
refuses to get married she really breaks
the princess mold she's courageous
strong and unafraid to speak her mind
this little girl looks so much like
Merida it's like we're seeing what the
character would have looked like as a
little girl
it's absolutely uncanny she has the
exact same eyes they're so big blue and
round they even have the same
mischievous look in them that the
princesses do one of the most iconic
features of the character is her bouncy
red hair just like the Scottish princess
this little girl has a huge amount of
red curls her hair is epic it's larger
than life
this little girl even has the same fair
skin as her Disney counterpart we just
can't get enough of her adorable smile
it's the same smart smirk that Merida
has we hope this little girl is just
like her princess twin maybe she's just
a sassy outspoken and strong as Merida
flash Zootopia is the best the movie is
full of awesome animal characters we
love every one of them the movie hit
hard and talks about some really serious
stuff it's not all cute bunnies and
fuzzy friends in the film Judy is a
sweet bunny rabbit she's also a police
officer she's an optimist who believes
in doing what's right she ends up
finding herself working with a grumpy
criminal wolf Nick Nick and Judy
couldn't be more different
they're total opposites maybe that's why
they end up being the perfect team
they're working together to solve the
series of crimes in their City
Judy tries to keep Nick's nose clean he
uses his street smarts and connections
to help Judy's investigation one of the
friends he introduces her to is flash
flash is pretty special he happens to be
the world's fastest sloth he works at
the DMV which is pretty hilarious it's a
great commentary on just how slowly
things move in a government office Korea
has it's very own flash her
is clover Kai oh she's so cute she's a
spitting image of the sloth she
obviously has no problem with the
resemblance she happily made a video of
herself impersonating the character Jack
Jack The Incredibles is an irresistible
movie it's about a loving family that
all happened to have superpowers
we love the over-the-top characters and
quotable lines from the film each member
of the family has their own unique
powers even the youngest member Jack
Jack Jack Jack is just a baby he's not
even walking or speaking yet he doesn't
have to be able to talk to his family to
be a valuable member of the team he has
a ton of awesome powers he can shoot
lasers out of his eyes become a wild
purple monster become a lead weight and
more babies are already a handful but
this little guy takes it to another
level
Jack Jack is completely adorable he has
the perfect little point of reddish
blond hair he also has two big round
blue eyes he has perfect brown baby
cheeks and pretty pale skin Jack Jack is
truly a gorgeous little boy Utah blogger
Danny Christensen knows just how cute
the character is she's the mom of two
little boys she's a lucky mama both of
her little boys are absolutely adorable
but her youngest looks really familiar
he has the same brown head big blue eyes
and strawberry blonde hair the two look
exactly alike
boo-boo is one of the cutest kid
characters in Disney history it's not
just her big curious brown eyes either
her precocious personality really adds
to the all factor of this character she
is really the catalyst for the whole
story she sets the whole thing in motion
when she escapes from her bedroom and
into the city of Monstropolis she ends
up shutting down the entire scare floor
in a world of monsters she's the
scariest thing around this little girl
is a pro status cosplayer she looks so
much like her character that it's hard
to believe boo isn't real look at this
perfect match her brown hair is the
exact same color those perky little
pigtails look exactly like the movie
this sweet little girls
are full of questions just like little
boo and she's too adorable for words
with her toy Mike and Scully look how
sweet she is with her monster friends
the resemblance is absolutely uncanny
the girl is sweet enough to eat
we hope she's just as cute funny and
inquisitive as her Disney doppelganger
Moana Bo wanna hit theaters like a tidal
wave fans flocked to the theaters night
after night the heroic story bold
emotions and fantastic music drew crowds
for weeks after the movie opened we love
the story so much it's one of the few
Disney stories in which there isn't a
princess searching for her prince
mallanna is doing just fine on her own
she can sail her own boat and won't take
anything from anyone she has the guts to
stand up to Maui and he's a demigod we
get to see a adorable baby Moana in the
movie we watch her grow up to be a
dedicated but torn daughter she wants to
be perfect to make her father proud but
she can't help but want to go exploring
Canadian cosplayer lad CK has dressed up
as a lot of characters but there's one
she looks exactly like in real life she
has the same full curly dark hair and
round gorgeous brown eyes every feature
of this artist looks exactly like Moana
we can't help but imagine her spending
her time with the chicken and a little
spotted pig how adorable is she we can't
get enough of this beautiful and
creative real-life mallanna we hope you
enjoyed this look at Disney characters
in real life we'll see you next time
[Music]